and yeah hello and welcome to this video
plane saw then say oh my god and hole
over there what is the text federated
now 1880 what you don't have a feed
rating of eighteen eighty with within
2414 and I am people right all kinds of
stuff in them in their profiles that
doesn't make any sense so we probably
transported to the roxy bind or he's
trying something else entirely okay here
probably t5 is an idea yeah he fire
phone comes into consideration
I mean isn't there not putting anything
in the center 94 um i have had a couple
of ideas ya hear h4 h5 comes into
consideration it is it is going to be
dangerous for black but also just
developing as good let me just develop
nothing handsome and maybe h3 as good I
yes yes the capture here and then I
26-foot might be as idea again maybe I
should have tried edge for tech to go
into full-scale punishment mode but
anyway this isn't bad the night on 85
hmm yeah I cannot take because of Queen
to f6
but they don't want to take uncle song
giving him the easy route bag
justing okay so I need I need f3 somehow
here but it's not easy to get in to
prevent any p5 yeah yeah and then denied
the five could be an idea
can I cannot play a free hand I wonder
if you will play a 4 and stuff yeah and
not not with any hesitation
fp3 is hanging at the end that's a bit
bit of an issue otherwise f3 would be
okay and I'm quite a lot down on time
yeah not nice but so what is this I
wonder if f3 is actually an idea with
III looks kind of looks awkward I don't
see anything constructive it's just not
good not a good position
oh no why didn't you get this for thi
morning okay that was bad light realize
that was bad a plate that min this is
okay it's a common pattern and this
opening is really not good but you
played very well afterwards yeah I
wonder probably yeah the engine is
giving age for it that was the move that
to get this screaming to be played of
course yeah full-scale punishment for
this but this is how you do it but like
go for made it this is this is the thing
and does these pieces are all bad and
you have to do something drastic
probably yeah and here the death was
excellently played we should be for most
of awkward this is where traders and now
now probably it's a matter of precision
never played b3 immediately it's going
to be better than because now we have
this if I move this is a fantastic move
if he does not play that his position
just sucks he has a week I porn he has a
misplaced night and so on me five is the
fantastically good move and it takes a
minutes very strong and what you know is
rated feature feeder 1800 you know and
all these other ratings are total crap
so he has a stroke of genius am great
stuff is fine
and no now this pollution is good for
black bags I need to play better I need
to plan it to get the F 3 n ya help
training off one piece would help him
but maybe thats that's not true I he
already 83 I did not see that route 35 s
is part of this then see a marathon
football player man after the opening ok
guys thanks for watching